[Music]
geolocation is pretty important like
uber is the highest-valued private tech
company in the world with a valuation of
over 100 billion and the core feature of
that app is real-time geolocation in
today's video we'll build some of the
most important features that go into an
app like uber such as device GPS
tracking and real-time geolocation
queries to a cloud database and we'll do
it all in under two hundred lines of
code using tools like flutter Google
Maps and firestorm if you're new here
like and subscribe and I highly
recommend following along with the
source code on fire ship IO and a huge
shout out to darshan goda not only did
he write most of the code for this video
but he's also the author of the geo
flutter fire library that powers the geo
queries that you'll see in this video
let's start by taking a closer look at
the app you'll notice it's a full-screen
google map and then we have a slider
down here in the left corner and a
button in the right corner in flutter we
can arrange this layout very simply in a
stack when we move the slider to the
right it will zoom out the camera and
also increase the range of our geo query
so the app allows you to find all of the
safe points within a certain radius of a
center point and more often than not
that center point will be the actual
users device location via GPS and the
button down here on the right allows us
to add a new geo point to firestore
based on the device's current location
but the really awesome thing is that we
can update the markers on the map by
reacting to events in the database so
you can see as this blue dot moves and
we add additional geo points they show
up on the map instantly that means you
could have multiple users listening to
the same stream of geo location data and
they would all get the same results in
the UI similar to that ubirr app how
everybody can see the same drivers
moving around in real time now let's go
ahead and get started
the first thing you'll need to do is
have flood or fire installed you can
refer to the official documentation
where I cover all the steps in the
Google OAuth Water video when you create
a firebase project it also gives you a
GCP project where you can obtain a
Google Maps API key once you have the
API enabled go ahead and copy that API
key and then we'll bring it into our
flutter project now let's take a look at
our dependencies we have firebase core
and cloud firestorm we're bringing in
our X start because we have some
relatively complex stream management to
deal with and then our geolocation
dependencies include geo flutter fire
location and Google Maps flutter and
keep in mind that the Google Maps
flutter package is very new
so there may be breaking changes in the
near future so just a heads up next
thing we'll do is go into the Android
app source directory and find the
Android manifest if you want to track
the user's location you'll need to
request permission to do so which we can
do with this tag and then we'll go down
here to the application and add some
metadata for the Google Maps API with
the API key that we obtained earlier
then for iOS we'll go into the Runner
appdelegate.m file and add our API key
there as well in the same directory
you'll find the info.plist we need to
add the following key value pairs to
obtain permission on the iOS device for
the user's location now we're ready for
the fun part of building the actual app
you'll notice I've commented out the
dependencies that we don't need yet I
will uncomment these as they become
necessary and right now we only need
Google Maps the app itself just starts
with a material scaffold and then we
have a stateful widget down here that
will encapsulate all of our state and
all of our logic so we can actually just
come up here and make the body of the
scaffold this fire map widget if you
want a map that's responsive it
perfectly centered and takes up the
entire screen I would recommend using a
stack this will allow us to set the map
on the bottom and then we can overlay
different controls as needed so we can
start by adding the google map widget as
the first widget in the stack it
requires an initial camera position
which is a latitude and longitude point
for the actual map to be centered on we
pass the coordinates into the target
option and you'll also want to set the
zoom level here as well at this point if
you run the app you should have a
full-screen map that looks similar to
this now the map itself has its own life
cycle hook called on map created we'll
set up a handler for that life cycle
event and the important thing that we do
here is set up the controller on this
widget the map controller is super
important because it allows you to
interact with the map by setting markers
on it zooming to a different position as
well as a bunch of other things so those
are the most important setup options
that you'll have for your map but you
can also do other things here too like
if you want to track the user's location
you'll set my location enabled to true
you can change the map type for example
if you want to show the satellite
imagery and the last thing we'll do for
this map is enable camera tracking so we
can always get the current center point
of the camera now that we have a basic
map set up let's add a control to it
we'll add a button to the bottom right
that can add a new marker based on the
cameras current position
we'll go back up to our stack in the
widget tree and add a new positioned
widget we can define the bottom and
right properties to put it in the bottom
right corner and then we'll define its
child as a flat button that has an icon
and when this button is pressed it will
trigger the add marker event handler now
we need to actually define this method
the first thing we'll do inside of it is
define the marker itself the first thing
we'll need to give it is a position and
we can do that by looking at the map
controllers camera position and that
will give us a latitude and longitude to
place the marker itself on the map we
can also customize the icon here and we
can also add information to the info
window text and that will be displayed
when the user clicks on the marker and
finally to add this marker to the map we
just called the map controller add
marker with this marker options object
now we should be able to pan around the
map and when we click the button it
should add a marker to the center the
next thing we'll do is use the flutter
location plug-in to track the users
actual position this is very easy and we
can get the user's location either as a
future or as a stream we'll go up here
to the top of our stateful widget and
set up a new instance of location now
we'll write a method called animate to
user that will animate the camera to the
users current location
this will be an async function and then
we can get the location by just calling
a wait location get location and you can
use on location change if you want to
listen to it as a real-time stream now
let's animate the camera to this users
position for that we can use the map
controller call animate camera and then
we'll update it with a new camera
position now we have a way to
programmatically control where the
camera is animated to and you can see
our current position is this little blue
dot in the middle of the screen at this
point we have a map the user's location
and the next phase is to save locations
in the firestore database you can see
here we have a locations collection and
you'll notice that every document in
this collection has a position field
that has a geo hash and a geo point geo
flutter fire will create this entire
data structure for you including the geo
hash value I'm not going to go into how
geohashes work in this video but it's
basically just an algorithm that allows
you to encode a bounding box on the
surface of a sphere in this case we're
talking about planet Earth and this is
important because we need this string to
be able to query firestore for
everything within a certain radius now
we'll go back to the top of our
application and import the remaining
dependencies
then notice in the stateful widget I'm
setting up a value for fire store and
also for the Geo Fire client before we
can query anything we first need to save
some geolocation data in the database
for that I'm creating an ad geo point
method and this is going to add a
document to firestorm which will always
return a future of a document reference
the actual value for the Geo point will
be the users current location so first
we'll get the location with our location
service and then we'll set up a geo
point based on that latitude and
longitude a Geo Fire point is just a
special data structure that's primarily
responsible for calculating that geo
hash but can also do other things like
calculate distances between points the
next step is to make a reference to the
collection that has our geolocation data
and then we'll define the position as
the point data and that's really all it
takes to add a geo point to firestore
for the users current location let's go
up to our button and replace the add
marker with the add geo point method you
can see I have fire store set up here
with an empty database and then as I
click this button it's adding new
documents to the database in real time
currently you'll notice that all these
geo points are the same that's because
it's based on the device location which
currently isn't changing but here's a
little tip if you're working on Android
specifically you can go into the
emulator settings and send your own
custom GPS locations to the device when
you push then you'll see the blue dot
move around the screen to the new
location and if we add another geo point
this time you'll see it's a different
geo hash and a different set of
coordinates now that we have a way to
get data into the database
let's query it and then add markers to
the map reactively the query itself is
based on a radius and we want to be able
to change that radius so we're defining
it as an RX behavior subject which is
basically an observable that we can push
new values to and always has the concept
of a current value it's an extremely
powerful data structure for dealing with
state management both on the web and in
flutter' the next value is our actual
geo query which is a stream of the
documents from the firestore database
and then we'll set up a another property
for the subscription this is definitely
the type of subscription that can result
in a memory leak so you'll want to make
sure to cancel it when this widget is
disposed now we'll go into our stack and
we'll add a slider so the user has a way
to actually change the radius value the
slider widget is built into flutter
material and it's pretty straightforward
we set a min and Max value and then
divide that by a certain number of set
we can always grab the current value
from our behavior subject by just
calling value on it so whenever set
state is called on the stateful widget
it will get the current value from that
radius subject and whenever the user
slides it will trigger this on changed
event which we can then use to update
the query but the query is the very last
thing I want to show you first I want to
show you what we do once we have the
actual documents from the database
anytime there's a change firestore will
emit the entire list of documents so we
can loop over them and update the
markers on the map this marker code is
almost identical to what I showed you
earlier the only difference is we're
taking the geolocation data from the
firestore document and using that for
the position of the marker and also geo
flutter fire will give us the actual
distance of this position from the query
center point we can use that data as the
info window text to show the user how
far they are from a given point in
kilometers the next step is to set up
the initial query and start listening to
it we'll start by getting the users
current location and then we'll make a
reference to the locations data and fire
store to make this query we need to
start from a Centerpoint four that will
set up a geo fire point based on this
user's location now our actual
subscription is dependent on two
different streams first we need to
listen to the radius value and then we
want to use that to query the database
and listen to the value of those
documents in real-time this is where I
really like to use rx start because we
can call switch map on the radius and
then switch to an observable of the
documents in the database and to make
that query we just call the geo fire
collection within and then we pass in
the center point the radius that we want
to search and then the property of the
document that contains the geo location
data and I also recommend using strict
mode here which will ensure that only
points within the radius are included in
the query otherwise you might get some
additional documents in the query that
go beyond the radius because of the way
geohashes are square-shaped
and lastly we called listen on the
stream and then we'll run our update
markers method that we defined earlier
the next step is to update the query
when the user slides the slider around
now just to make this a little more
polished I created a map of different
zoom values so we can zoom out when the
user goes to a higher radius that part
is optional but the important thing is
that you call set state here and then
add a new value to the radius behavior
subject so we already have that set up
on our slider the last thing we have to
do is call start query
when our map is created and it's also
probably a good idea to come down here
and override the dispose method and
cancel that subscription when this
widget is destroyed and that's all there
is to it we should now have a demo that
allows us to change the radius and
update that query and responds to that
change and it's pretty crazy to think
that we just built a real-time
geolocation app in about ten minutes
that runs on both iOS and Android I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you have any questions
leave me a comment below or reach out on
slack thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]